all right the movie the farewell is
getting praised for its touching
portrait of a family it tells the story
of family members coping with the news
their grandmother has terminal cancer
they decide not to tell her and to stage
a wedding in China as an excuse to visit
and say goodbye the median and wrapper
aquafina plays billy her granddaughter
who struggles with keeping the secret i
need a collar you can't do that I go see
her I can't do that she doesn't know the
family thinks it's better not to tell
her so you can't say anything I
understand she didn't have a lot of time
left she should know right there's
nothing they can do so everyone decided
it's better not to tell her why is that
better Chinese people have same when
people get Kenza they die it's not the
cancer that kills them it's the fear the
movie was the breakout head of the
Sundance Film Festival this year earning
the film's writer director Lulu Wong the
festival's Vanguard Award the farewell
is based on her own life story Lulu
joins us at the table good morning
welcome congratulations thank you I saw
this in an absolutely packed theater I
have to admit even here in New York I
was kind of stunned that an audience
sat still for a film that was primarily
subtitled they reacted and laughed at
everything it's it's amazing how people
are responding to this thank you yeah
it's pretty surreal yeah this started
because of something that actually
happened to you yes yeah so an actual
lie that happened in my family my mother
called me to tell me that my grandmother
was diagnosed with terminal cancer and
that we weren't gonna tell her and if we
wanted to go back to see her it was
under the ruse of a wedding for my
cousin she is and we're gonna I'm not
gonna give away the ending of this story
but your grandmother is still living and
she still doesn't know that's got to be
a tough secret to keep with the movie
coming out yeah
one of the themes that I found really
fascinating in the film is the idea of
the collective good and that's something
that you sort of drive home Aquafina
sort of I guess standing in for you
raised in America so it has a
sensibility of the way we operate here
in the United States which we don't ever
imagine that we would keep something
like that from somebody but at one point
a character says look we are mourning
for that person who is afflicted with a
horrible terminal illness
we take that on we take on that pain and
then the United States it's all about
the individual and it's not like that in
China yeah yeah so the film you know
plays with this the theme of
collectivism versus individuality and I
think that you know awkwafina's
character Billy as an American she very
much believes in truth and freedom as
the most important values and you know
her Chinese family says well are those
really good values if it doesn't really
serve the person that you're telling the
truth - if it doesn't serve the family
and you know it's also the sense of duty
that if she tells the grandmother the
truth she's not the person who's going
to be around to deal with the results of
that truth being told you know so if the
grandmother gets depressed and his that
stops eating and stop sleeping she's not
the person who actually has to deal with
those consequences the sister is the one
who does and she says you know I know my
sister the best and this is what I
believe is best for her yeah I love the
relationship between the two systems yes
they're both right they're really
terrific you know Americans got to know
Aquafina from from her portrayal of the
best friend in crazy rich Asians why did
you cast Aquafina as Billy here she's a
comedian she's terrific
she's taking a really dark role here
yeah well when I first met with her I
was pretty surprised that she wanted to
do this I thought you know you're a
rapper from Queens like but why did this
resonate with you and she said she was
raised by her Chinese grandmother
because her mother passed away when she
was four and you know just really
connected with the story with the
relationship between Billy and her
grandmother and
said you know I got to do this and she
sent an audition tape in and when I saw
the audition tape I was blown away I
just didn't know that she had that in
her she's really terrific I'm curious
when you brought the idea of this film
to sort of Hollywood Finance ears how
they reacted to it oh they were like
take all the money
subtitled all Asian cats where's my
check interested at least yes they were
interested in the premise
you know they felt like oh this ruse
this facade it's kind of screwball let's
take that and let's run with it let's go
more screwball let's go broader let's
make this my big fat Chinese wedding
let's put a white character in they
wanted a white character him that was
actually a Chinese investor he said you
know if we're gonna bring this film to
Chinese audiences the thing that's gonna
be entertaining for them to watch is
somebody who's American I said well
Billy's American he said no no no like a
real American real American right
exactly like a white guy that she brings
home doesn't understand the culture and
well laugh at the fact that he can't use
chopsticks like that's not the story so
glad you were able to hold on to your
vision for this film because it's a
beautiful film and it's a wonderful film
for people who are trying to understand
the way others around the world may
think of tradition and duty and it's
just it's also it's a universal film too
because I think everybody can see their
own family and that's why the response
has been so good Lulu Wong thank you
very much thank you that's what the film
we appreciate your visit here the
farewell is in theaters nationwide now